let's get back to the 16 minutes
interview we have this uh this tweet
here from benny johnson
what do you think of people who say you
are unfit for the job of president biden
says watch me the proof of the pudding
is in the eating now uh this is a real
quote and i think young people just
don't know it because we go by the
shorter the proof is in the pudding but
the actual old idiom i guess is as biden
expressed it but it's not it's not just
that i want to i want to play for you
this clip and then we will we will roast
joe biden you are the oldest president
well let's turn it down a little bit
there you go put it into ever pretty
good shape huh no which leads to my next
question
you are more aware of this than anyone
some people ask whether you are fit for
the job some people and when you hear
that
i wonder what you think
watch me
watch me
and my honest to god that's all i think
watch me
if you think i don't have the energy
level or the mental acuity then
then you know that's one thing
it's another thing is just watching and
you know keep my schedule
what do what i'm doing i i think that uh
you know i don't when i sit down with
our nato allies and keep them together i
don't have them saying wait a minute
old do you what do you want to say
you know i mean it's a matter of you
know
that old expression the proof of the
puddings and the eating i mean
i i respect the fact that people would
say you know you're old and but i think
it relates to
how much energy you have and whether or
not the job you're doing is one
consistent with what any person of any
age would be able to do how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
i say it's i think it's i i haven't look
i have trouble even mentioning
even saying to myself my own head the
number of years i no more think of
myself as being as old as i am than fly
i mean it's just not uh he is fly
what did he just say
why okay he said i have
trouble even mentioning saying to myself
the number of years in my head yep the
number of years of what what's he
talking about how old he is i can't
believe i'm 75 he wants to see what he's
trying to do and then he says i know
what does he say i don't think of myself
as old as i am than fly
at the very beginning he's like so
people think you're old and he was like
looking pretty good huh and then scott
pelley just looks away he can't even
look him in the eyes when he says it
oh my god maybe he's stuck in the 80s
he's like i'm pretty fly it's like well
we stopped saying that when like marky
mark stopped rapping this was by now
it's like full defense mode he's whining
he keeps talking like this and he can
talk if i talk to you guys like this
look it would sound like i was trying to
hide something if i always talk like
this
like if somebody such an annoying tone
if somebody if i was sitting down with
an interviewer and they were like tim
some people think that you are unfit to
host this show i would go why
well here's what they said like oh okay
well i disagree i don't know what else
you want me to say
the fact that biden gave all of these
answers shows that he knows exactly what
his problems are and he has to try and
address them in a way or counter them
because the reality is he knows exactly
why people are saying it thus he gave
this long-winded drawn-out wishy-washy
response that ultimately ended in
nonsense yeah but look at how polite
that he gets the open-ended question
like some people are saying this
you know how does that make you feel or
what would you say in that if it was
someone who scott pelley didn't like it
would be like why should we believe you
when you think when you say you're
healthy enough to be president like why
why should we trust that you have the
mental acuity like it would be so much
more defensive so much more attacking
but with biden it's this open-ended how
does that make you feel he says do what
i do like are you are you telling the
people who think you're unfit
to be
president to copy your schedule and see
if they can do it yeah
that is this is him also uh allegedly
being drugged up because there's some
sources there's some rumors out there
that he's being fed a whole bunch of
drugs right before these interviews and
then the interviewer here is still not
doing his job
like you encounter be like sometimes
five right now
or just look shock and like explain
yourself more here because this
absolutely makes no sense at all and if
there ever was an argument that there is
a shadowy secretive government ruling
things behind the scenes this is it
right there
just just because i recently finished
watching breaking bad that the instant
joke i get is that there should we
should do a gag where it's this
interview and then it like cuts to uh
slightly behind the scenes with walter
white being like get it right
say it
like
all hopped up on on blue sky meth this
is um biden got these questions ahead of
time and then
i assume they do all the time and then
cbs sent this interview to the white
house before they aired it to make sure
everything was clear in five days if the
interviewer had actually been like okay
you're saying you're fine i'm watching
you walk around the oval office and
you're you're shuffling left and right
and looking like an old man they would
have been like interviews over get them
out of here and they wouldn't have run
it if this was a real interview the
interview would have been like you're
kidding me right like you're joking
right the leslie stahl interview also 60
minutes of president trump how hostile
it was how nasty i mean it was it was a
vicious interview because she hates him
and they let their true colors fly i
tweeted this earlier today daniel turner
power of the future then ptf on twitter
i tweeted this earlier today if you were
the president's white house coms team
and it's been 210 days since he's done
an interview and you're like holy crap
we got to break the streak they chose 60
minutes and scott pelly for a reason and
it's not because they're top-notch
journalists yes they wanted softballs
this is what people need to understand
too these interviews have always been
selectively edited yeah always i love
how they like to rag on project veritas
like the videos that selectively edited
it it's like they're doing an undercover
operation i do think in many
circumstances james should publish the
raw archives be like here's our
editorial like that we published here's
the raw footage make up your own mind i
thought one the most but this these
interviews since the inception of 60
minutes have always been edited and
people don't understand that i guarantee
you
he's he asks a question there are
certain points in the interview because
i watched it where you'll it'll it'll
it'll show joe biden talking and then
it'll cut to scott pelley like just like
shaking his head and nodding that's a
trick so they can edit the audio of
biden without making it seem like they
did an edit because they get a they get
a still shot of
30 seconds of pelly but then they take
two 45 second bidens mash them together
and put his video over it so you don't
see it thank you for bringing that up
especially when he asked him about
taiwan and this is an old thing they
used to do in the 80s too i remember but
i didn't realize it was the media
manipulation like you're talking about
till today he asked them would you use
military troops would you put american
troops in taiwan if china were invaded
and biden goes yes and then biden starts
to clarify he goes some and then
immediately it edits to scott pelley and
his voice talking over biden's response
to arguably the most important question
ever asked of a u.s president uh in the
last month or year or whatever of our
generation literally going to work china
and um and it's scott pelley talking
over biden's response you can't even
understand what biden was saying and
then it cuts back to biden saying the
end of his response and they edited out
biden's response
people need to get this
this interview was probably
substantially longer and then way cut
down i guarantee you
in this in this video i'm willing to bet
biden probably went
and they're like okay we'll cut that out
and then we'll get his answer
because here's what we know
we know that when biden speaking live he
says things like nexenel rescind batacaf
care true in an honest shop at a
pressure trinity shop at a pressure what
else has he said
i got those three there's a few more
he says things that make no sense and
he's angry and he gets angry very but
here's the important piece
i will listen to joe biden and he'll say
something like you know we got an
economy man you gotta
extraord up strengthen uh inflation's
bad and then you'll read nbc and they'll
say the president said the economy needs
to be shored up its strength because
inflation is getting bad and you're like
he did not say that yeah daley wire took
a great uh you read that one yeah yeah
we i don't even pull that tweet up
but it's play-by-play and and i i hope i
hope that uh
well i'm glad the daily wire understands
this when you read an article from the
daily wire they quote biden and it says
i i uh what's it uh you know well the
economy is uh dot dot dot and i they put
it all in there yeah here's the quote
biden on his mental focus oh focused
haha i'd say it's
it's it is i haven't here look i have
trouble even mentioning it even saying
to myself in my head the number of years
i no more thinking of myself being old
as i am than fly
that's a literal transition
i'm surprised that the white house ran
that that response that's insane he's
not saying i'm fly no but that's how i'm
interpreting oh right
i think what he's trying to say is i'm
older than dirt no no he's saying let me
let me try and give a different sentence
i he says something like i wouldn't do a
backflip as soon as like
he's basically saying
to the same degree of which i fly i
think of myself as old which is not
that's you know what i mean oh that's
what he's trying to write exactly
exactly and i'm translating for him and
now tim poole translates joe biden but
this is the point the media has to try
and just decode it's like it's like
we're sitting in a bunker and we've got
a little wheel we're spinning it like
i'm trying to figure out what he's
saying it's like i can't figure it out
can you play the fly part again just the
part where he says i no longer think of
me being focus is
oh it's focused
i say it's i think it's i i haven't look
hold on a minute i'm sorry i got to stop
right there how's your mental focus it's
focused exactly what they jump there's a
cut there there's a cut there hold on
let me let me play the question again
each would be able to do how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
i believe he said how would you say your
mental focus is there was some kind of
back and forth and then they edited that
response and because it's focused what
did the subject change to when he said
that question because the subject was
biden he's referring to himself as it or
his mental focus as it no no mental
focus was the subject or he was the
subject so we wouldn't say my friend if
when he says it he's saying my mental
focus is focused yeah but he was the
subject not the focus
he's calling himself it no they edited
something out of there but let's play
more
i say i think it's i i haven't look
i have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years i know more think of myself as
being as old as i am than fly
i think i get it now when he when he
said the years there's a missing context
they edited out a chunk of that you're
right when he said
um
i have trouble mentioning saying even
myself the number of years
they must have
had a back and forth
following up on what the question was
confusing biden
mention something about well like you
know you've been in in for how many
years right so you've been in for 50
somebody years so so how would you say
how would you say it it's going and you
and then well it's focused you know yeah
and and i know more i i have trouble
mentioning myself the number of years
that the context of where the years fits
into this conversation makes no sense
age it's how long he's been working at
this it sounds like to me it sounds like
they cut out a huge chunk of this and
biden was probably rambling that's why
that's why the white house okay that
response this was the best they got out
of that response because how's your
mental focus it's focused it's not
something you want someone to respond
yeah so i don't think i'm too old to do
this job anymore than i think i can fly
as like whether he was going to say
something like that or i don't think um
he's saying like i don't think of myself
as he says he's basically saying i think
of myself as old as often as i fly
which is never a gotcha but but it's
confusing because he flies in planes all
the time so it's like
are you talking about flapping your
wings like
you know when i first heard that i had
to sit down and actually i'm like
looking at the quote
first you read the transcript and you're
like this makes no sense i have no idea
what he's trying to convey
then you hear him say it and you go
wait hold on when i saw the first
transcript it was t-h-e-n
then i saw the daily wire write t-h-a-n
and i'm like i am i have this guy's out
of his
mind is than fly a thing we don't know
about is there a thing fly is that like
so it's it's that or then
then fly like he's saying i don't i
think of myself as old as often as i
flies no if he says this and the five of
us sitting around this table who were
all fairly intelligent or struggling
at the beginning of his comment he talks
about look when i sit down with the nato
partners imagine what they're really
thinking like what are we going to war
like what
he went to the g7 and he said we're
going after libya libya libya and
everybody did go what
when when is this happening oh did he
mean syria syria libya and i and i tell
people when when they try and downplay
this stuff the severity of it is joe
biden's going to be in the situation
room and he's going to be like so so
give me the brief and they're going to
be like we've got you know baghdadi
we've got these guys we got this guy
here's the region they're moving in and
the middle east and north africa it's
it's a large swath of territory that has
overlap between some of these groups and
he's gonna go we need to
get a missile strike in libya and
they'll be like the libyan target like
yeah the libya and they'll go
well the the the the the problem is
centered over here and
i said libya and they'll go
okay all right they'll go to the
generals and be like he wants to strike
and move in on libya and they're gonna
be like why
what nothing's happening now but this is
what the commander-in-chief is ordered
now
i don't think they would actually follow
through because i think the white house
has gone rogue let's jump to this next
story and i'll tell you but i'll wrap up
that thought basically jill woodstock
imagine a circumstance where they go you
got a boss and then all of a sudden you
got terrorists outside of syria and then
libya is being bombed repeatedly well a
situation like that is like go get him
go kick his door down go to donald
trump's house and get blah blah like
these erratic you know almost
nonsensical moves are like really
intense weird out of the sideways things
and they will go for it sometimes so so
you're saying the raid on trump was
actually it could have been like an old
man angry it was an oh won't someone
ridden me of this priest i don't know he
says he didn't know anything about
donald trump somebody ought to write his
house take some documents from him he's
there
i don't care what about the borders or
the means justify the ends justify the
answers thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you